okay guys it is the 27th of January my
name is Jess ideas what matters in
gaming tonight if you spent any part of
your star wars battlefront playtime
cursing up a storm at boba fett you'll
be happy to hear the dude got nerfed in
the game's most recent update Boba Fett
along with Han Solo will now deal less
damage at higher distances the radius
and damage associated with Rovers wrist
launcher has also been lowered and his
missile no longer locks on these changes
are being implemented as part of the
January update which is out now the
update also brings a number of weapon
tweaks the card changes new maps and
skin as well as gameplay and bug fixes
yeh has announced that it will not have
a booth at e3 this year and it's
freezing will take place on Sunday
afternoon as the poster later in the
week instead the company will have an
event called in a play where people can
stop by club nokia in la live which is
right next to the LA Convention Center
from jun 12 to 14 to play ea's games and
check out live events EA his said
tickets will need to be reserved in
advance due to limited space but they
will be free a representative told
GameSpot the publisher will still host
private meetings during e3 finally
street fighter 5 producer Yoshinori
owner has spoken about toning down the
sexualization of the game's female
characters owner told GameSpot you may
have seen some time ago for our makers
critical art cutscene the camera angle
was changed a bit and we made some other
changes with how the camera angles
worked with the characters we want
everyone to be able to enjoy playing
this game we don't want anything
offensive in there we want everyone to
be able to enjoy the game as much as
possible so we're working to be able to
provide a friendly environment for
everyone oh no said the decision came as
a response to criticism over the
betrayal of certain characters although
he noted that he has personally received
abuse on his Twitter accounts from
people who opposed the changes he added
that fans shouldn't be worried as Capcom
have a good handle on
identity of the franchise even though
they have chosen to respond to feedback
he explains we may be making more
adjustments moving forward but the
fighting experience the battle is the
same street fighter 5 is due out ps4 and
PC on februari 16 let me know down in
the comments how you feel about EA se
for you present this year and be sure to
head to gamespot or we've got stories on
rise of the Tomb Raider on DC and tekken
7 that is everything I wanted to tell
you about today as always let me know
what matter to you and I will catch the
same time tomorrow